[Music]
up next is shelley in san antonio texas
hi shelly how are you
i'm
doing pretty well waiting for as long as
i've been waiting um
getting teary-eyed so you have to
i have to apologize
no troubles um
i lost my husband in february
suddenly i'm sorry i mean he was 61. i'm
60.
but um
and
i had i gave my son
the job of handling my finances
which was probably really a mistake but
i knew i couldn't do it
and he's done a good job he's gotten the
financial planner he's he's done a while
but all of a sudden
i kept telling him he was playing with
stock
and all of a sudden
they found out that there's like
27 000 in stocks
but i don't know how much he put into it
so i know there's going to be taxes that
to do
is going to be
and
i mean i have a house that i only own 38
000 on
how much other money is there other than
this twenty seven thousand in stocks
well we hadn't done very well with city
money
um we had
i think he knew things were happening
because
he bought extra life insurance
but it was
375 000 dollars in life insurance and
you've got that money
i had that money in the [ __ ] with the
financial planner okay and i'm pulling
a monkey amount out yeah how long have
you all been married
uh we have been married 40 years
i'm sorry shelly
and they had waited for five so we were
high school sweethearts yeah and worked
together forever i'm so sorry
so um
what what did uh
did you work outside the home
i did for a while and when i stayed home
with the kids what did you do
i was a
preschool teacher or i worked
with insurance and neither one cannot do
now
um for disability reasons okay all right
so here's the here's the thing let me
let me give you an assignment can i
would you allow me to do that
sure okay
um
you do not need a babysitter
you are a 60 year old woman and you're
perfectly capable
your heart is broken
and your stomach stays in your throat
several minutes or hours a day
because of grief and that just means
that you loved your husband and you're a
wonderful woman that's all that means
okay and it does it does make it hard to
think clearly while the tiers are this
close to the top all the time
but you're capable and i do not want you
to have a 20-year game plan you're only
60.
i do not want you to have a 20-year game
plan of your son and your financial
planner making all your decisions
i do want them to stay in your corner
and advise you
but i want you to get on top of this
over the next year you have one year to
do it that's your assignment
i want you to understand what's going on
with this instead of asking them what
you can do
ask them what you should do
and then you make your own decisions i
want you to have some power again
know because i'm like i don't even know
how much i had in the 401k i know
there's still before and that you know
what that causes that causes you to
worry about stuff you may not even need
to be worrying about
right because you don't have knowledge
of what's going on and you don't have
power if you were the only one that said
something's going to happen until you
said it it didn't happen
after you
i don't mind them being in your corner
and saying mom i think this is wise or
the financial planner going ma'am i
think this is a good idea and here's
what you could do and you look at that
you go well
okay but you don't say i did this
because my financial planner said to you
do this because i looked at it i
understood it and i am going to make the
decision now it's going to take you a
little while to get that kind of power
right now because you're dealing with a
broken heart
right and plus i i need to add to the
situ to the story
he stood beside me
as i was an alcoholic
are you still an alcohol as an alcoholic
you're always an alcoholic but
are you sober now
no as i've been as time has gone on
through the holidays i've been drinking
more okay
then you don't need to make decisions in
that setting until if you're not going
to be sober you don't need to make
decisions
so you're wise to share that so now you
have two assignments
ready for the second one
get sober amen
that's what he would want
that's what he would want he always
wanted
that's what he always wanted
and it's your best life isn't it it was
my best life when i was over yes ma'am
okay
so that'll give you the power back
inside me
and
the church stood beside me
and
let me just tell you i'm going to stand
beside you i'm going to stand beside you
but the problem with me standing beside
you is i'm also going to kick your butt
because i love you and you're going to
straighten up girl okay
i am all right
but i i'm just wondering about
you when you invest i don't know how
much you invested i don't either
i think i'm going to sell that stock and
pay it pay off your house it's probably
what i'm going to do
but but we got more important things
than the 27 000 and the 38 000. we got
375 000 land over there we got to get
you sober and we got to get you where
you're making the decisions with a a
clear mind and be from a position of
power and knowledge and you don't have
either one right now
okay so but probably when i get you to a
clear mind and in power say march
you're sober till march
and you're starting to meet with this
financial planner and with your son and
you're understanding what's going on and
they're not having to take care of you
because you're drunk
they're taking care of you and walking
with you and loving you as you're coming
into power and you're throwing your
shoulders back and becoming the woman
that you're supposed to be
then you're going to make the decision
to pay off this house by selling the
stock and maybe a little bit of that 375
as well and that's going to be a good
decision but that's probably not worry
about that today
okay i just want to make sure i have
enough to move on so now uh i mean my
house payment's only 700
so
i'm you know
okay don't have this two thousand dollar
house yeah i know but i just want you to
have no payments and have the income
coming in
and that's only
on that besides my car is the only one
that i have so one more thing okay
i want to put you into financial peace
university
in ramsey plus
so i can teach you rachel and i and the
rest of the team here at ramsey can
teach you how to handle money and give
you this power
in this area of money so that you get a
sense of control here if i give you this
class for free will you promise to go
through it
yes i will okay
and i need you to call me back in march
and tell me that you're sober and that
you're getting on top of this stuff okay
i will do that all right we love you
darling you hold on and austin will pick
up and we'll get you signed up for this
stuff
but uh church standing beside you
husband standing beside you son standing
beside you
um
and dave and rachel now standing beside
you but understand that what comes with
that is accountability we're gonna we
want you to have your best possible life
and that's gonna involve the things
we've been talking about here today and
i know your heart's broken honey i know
your heart's broken
that was good though i think that that's
a that's a good message of just the the
knowledge brings clarity and it brings
confidence
for everyone so shelley
i pray all good things for you amen